Welcome back.
I'm now going to actually do a
couple more rates of change
problems because I think the
first one I did was probably a
little bit more complicated
than I wanted, and the hard
part was actually the geometry
and not the calculus.
So let's just say I drop
a rock into a pond
and it has a ripple.
And the ripple spreads out--
it'll probably have multiple
ripples, but let's just say
we focus on one ripple.
And the ripple is
spreading out.
So let me draw.
This is where I dropped the
rock, and then this is
a ripple in the pond.
It would be an actual
circle, which isn't what
I drew, but close enough.
So let me say that--
let's call r.
r is not for ripple.
r is the distance that the
ripple is from the center
from where it started
from the get go.
And it's not by chance that
that's also for radius.
So let's say that the
ripple is moving out at
2 meters per second.
So the rate at which r is
changing with respect to t
is 2 meters per second.
And what I want to know is what
is the rate at which the area
that's kind of included by this
ripple-- this entire area-- how
fast is that changing
with respect to time.
When the ripple is let's say
3 meters from the center.
When the ripple is
equal to 3 meters.
Well do we know any relation
between the area of the circle
essentially, and the distance
of the ripple, or the radius?
Well yes we do.
Area is equal to pi r squared.
So we want to figure out the
rate at which area changes
with respect to time.
So what does a chain
rule tell us?
The chain rule tells us that
the rate at which a changes
with respect to t is equal to
with respect to r times the
rate at which r changes
with respect to t.
Well we already know
this piece, right?
We already know the rate
at which r is changing
with respect to time.
That's right here.
All we have to do to figure out
the rate at which a is changing
with respect to time is we have
to figure out the rate at which
a changes with respect to r.
Well that's just
the derivative.
The derivative with
respect to r.
The derivative with respect to
r-- do it of both sides-- of a
equals the derivative with
respect to r of pi r squared.
So we get da/dr is equal
to-- what's the derivative
with respect to r here?
Well that's easy.
Just 2 times pi r to the 1.
That's pretty interesting by
itself that the rate at which
the derivative of the area--
formula really-- is what?
This formula by itself
looks interesting, right?
That's a formula for the
circumference of a circle.
So the derivative of an area of
a circle with respect to the
radius is a circumference.
That is mildly fascinating.
Something even more interesting
is to figure out what the
antiderivative is of the area
and compare that to the
volume of a sphere.
You can look it up on
Wikipedia or something.
Or even compare that to the
surface area of the sphere, and
just keep picking derivatives
and integrals and they'll be
some pretty interesting
relationships.
But anyway.
Back to the problem.
Not to go on too
far of a tangent.
So we figured out the
rate at which 8 changes
with respect to r.
So going back to our original
thing, we now know that the
rate at which a changes with
respect to t is equal to the
rate at which a changes
with respect to r.
Well that's just
right here, right?
The rate at which a changes
with respect to r.
Well that's just 2 pi r times
the rate at which r is
changing with respect to t.
Well the rate at which r
changes with respect to
t is just right here.
2 meters per second,
we figured that out.
So 2 pi r times 2-- well I
won't include the units
because that might
confuse you right now.
So the rate at at which a
is changing with respect
to t is 2 pi r times 2.
Well are we done yet?
Well no, because we haven't
substituted yet for r.
So what is r?
Well we know. r is three
meters, so da/dt is equal to
2 times pi times 3 times 2.
So what is that?
2 times 3 is 6 times 2 is 12.
12 pi and it's meters squared
per second, because it's the
rate at which area-- square
meters-- is changing
with respect to time.
And if we multiply out the
units we would have gotten
the same thing right here.
So in the next video i'm going
to do a slightly harder rate of
change problem just so that you
see that it doesn't only apply
to kind of purely
geometric things.
It applies to pretty much
anything that you can
find a relationship
between two values.
See you in the next module.